all right we're back you want support
you want vitality total human
optimization total gut health total mike
mitochondria - krill oil shroom tech
immune be active beat compar complex
yeah he mineral he's off the entire body
they got everything you want yes check
yep they got it all Brian keep listing
out all the supplements on my page there
dude they got total keyed off your
Aikido kid like myself
they got workout gear they got the best
supplements on planet for you on it you
guys know them there were some of the
best names in the world
there's a reason use it the best name I
use it you can save 10% off their
workout gear their supplements go to
audit calm / fighter and save 10% off
everything optimize so Brendan looks
like I'm gonna be wearing a whoop well
here it is why because I convinced you
because my thick ass I've been working
out and I begin these reads on whatever
device some workout they go you burned a
thousand know you bring 1200 now you
didn't bro because now whoop is the most
calculated accurate device you can rock
look pretty thin here like looks like a
bracelet but it also talks about sleep
sleep is important sleep attraction how
much sleep you need heart rate how hard
you can go for the next workout your
maximum maximum levels where you're at
it's the most accurate calculation I
want advice I want the new whoop strap
3.0 it's includes new upgrades and
hardware and unlocks a suite of new
software features for their app this the
whoop strap 3.0 now has a five-day
battery life damn yeah bro strap guess
what though this attracts my heart rate
a hundred times per second 24/7 recovery
we got you covered
rest recover your workout how many
calories are you burning everything man
they take all that and count it's the
most accurate detailed it's it's wo p
it's a whoop strap yep whoop down it out
number like that whoop it I get it how
do I get it
dude how do you get it you go to whoop
calm that's wh oo p calm use the code
fighter and you get $30 off your whoop
membership yes Optima
the way you train get shred City with me
get shred City woop calm promo code
fighter $30 off who is that
Bella Hadid god dang she's getting hot
man oh really grown into her tits
oh yeah I squandered that I just want
you to know that before we started this
podcast Brandon was talking about
someone he goes god damn she's really
grown in their tits
it's a grown first two grown woman she's
really grown into her tits
Bella Hadid yeah all right man [ __ ]
over there you know yeah flat and stuff
boys y'all flat what when she was 14
because now she's [ __ ] you know like
she's grown up over ice yeah I don't
know man I don't know I just feel the
mohel Bonjour no new fighter and the kid
if its own life a inspiring kid fans a
much khuda fans bow [ __ ] a lot of fans
beaucoup dude hey hold up yeah French
for AP here high school I did was a
French I like that fluent in French bro
ruffles even oh sweet sweet cash get
your video Matt Nam can you show us no
no duck oh that's good no go back you
back long um be methanol it's been a
while so I will remember for years high
school yeah it's been a lot of a long
time okay whether you unless you use it
you lose it use it or [ __ ] lose it
now Montreal brothers Jeff I love
Montreux heard you had a great show I
had a great show I like using all my new
[ __ ] is hitting it's so fun you know how
it is
well you're not yet but you will but but
you do in a little way because when you
when you throw away your old stuff and
you're trying to come up with new shall
we have new yeah and so for me I put
everything I could in too complicated
apron and for like probably three months
I couldn't write anything I was like I
don't know what else to write about and
the end of each other stuff yes but then
it hit me
and now it's just been writing itself
and it's fun so it was all whoa there's
a bunch of peeps in Montreal my piece
were there you are
Lewis from alka he was there I I saw the
I saw Lewis I saw last dinner AJ was
there I saw Justin I saw I trained you
know how I train I train on the road and
I don't sniff like that well you know
okay
none up in Montreal where'd you go broke
my legs in my are my legs my hips look
look a little bit more story it's cuz I
push the sled and I do other stuff I do
scientific workouts with my friend John
chamber who has a channel hold on don't
see your friend cuz John's 8th my coach
hold on boys hey he's my road coach not
hold on that's fair I can view meet no
not take this with grace if you meet
anybody in the fight world yeah my
friend also the only reason I know you
me now oh that was at my actual coach he
was your coach I found that out for a
long time when he worked me out he might
an Ultimate Fighter coach I understand
that and I I didn't realize that until I
was there and then I realized who's
trans GSP was friend bro ok trains a lot
of guys I would fly up to Montreal just
to train with him ok I didn't know that
ok take it easy I see yes so don't you
know my friend micboys my road coach has
seen him bit through some [ __ ] ok even
my road coach though he kind of went as
I was doing as I was pushing the sled he
was like [ __ ] and I go what he goes [ __ ]
him in shape and I go oh yeah dude he
goes and he goes and I go what he
doesn't ever mind I go what he goes
would you ever want to start fighting I
go no dude I don't that never I can't I
can't
guys either well he's a scientist what
was amazing about a guy on jacob's
ladder he didn't put me on Jacob's
Ladder oh do I because I just gotta have
a plane that was tired yeah sounds like
an excuse I've done that yeah and went
on Jacob's Ladder
yeah I've seen dudes break is that true
is that true he his workouts were so
tough well she's owed he said to me
sleds the ladders cuz he said to me he
goes we'll just get your body moving now
he knows how old I am
he's not a macho guy he's not he's not
gonna try to break me but I known for
breaking people you know dude not with
you it was so obvious he could have done
that but he was what was like anal for
your first time you know for my first
time gentle but he knew exactly how
strong I was he knew her and I was gonna
fail
he put the weight it just got did it -
and by by 8 he tell me do a tower
[ __ ] done and I was like this guy no
such dude - gotcha giddy I mean was GSB
I think still that trainer tonight as
far as strengthing he is he is GSP is
head trainer he's reason why I just
begun gymnastics and full body movement
crazy he's a monster and and he not only
I could take an aspirin the next day I
did not only train stands as well
ducklings don't go in that Jenna I'm
glad you brought your now welcome now it
doesn't say that butts like Hooters well
his girlfriend is his girlfriend is a
1111 now he has a booty class there and
he has the women that work out there
that it's it's well it's a problem well
sir problem if you're a gay man it's a
problem if you're even if you're a gay
man you go oh I thought I was gay and
now I'm straight because you've never
seen bodies like that I've seen a bro
you've seen it I've seen it oh boy you
were young with a shaved head and
fighting a fat dick ah no hot real
freezin my ass up gotta get warm you got
to get warm got to get warm so we're we
in do so let me ask you something Oh
Papa speaks French where he's out there
hey Oh Papa speaks French speaks French
sign language really French because your
training but your training bro you gotta
fight but everybody needs a little
leisure time well everyone needs a
release
so did you indulge the Montreal release
it scrolled famously I didn't know that
I didn't know that
hey they do have the hottest women so
strata know how much real well so my boy
Joel Gerson who you've met who you know
Jojo Scott Joseph Prince in Toronto yeah
it's got that town locked up I mean my
Joe's right there with Drake i'ma rip
your dick up no not like now we trained
as far as like this with women like
knowing people that I agree it's like
you're like every girl nice bodies like
Jared J how you doing everybody it's
nuts
Jerry's a terrible name I don't care it
they're super hot super hot girls to me
named Ted Jim yeah you can always get
your Jerry Jerry Dave hot was right nice
back although I said Jerry
well because Zeppelin all mmm but I will
say I've been I've hit I said a lot of a
lot of the spots on the globe right real
Toronto back I got Montreux maybe it's
my number one for real I mean overall
overall I might have I might roll number
one is 500 crazy to say cuz I love Miami
Miami Dontrell positive attitudes Miami
everyone's mean well they're just
they're just spicy Miami is Miami is
spicy
I know but much the positive attitudes
Montreal's got that French and there's a
lot of I think there's a lot of darker
women so they have that cuz because
there's a lot of native there was a lot
of native mixing with a friend that's a
lot of it it's like yeah rat that do the
Native Americans there so so there's
that oh it's this melting pot Dainese
it's just this big batch of diamonds
it's a problem you know what I mean it's
a problem or it's an awesome problem you
just get that spoon by spoon I mean your
[ __ ] and just jump into the city man
that sounds like a recipe for chlamydia
man take it easy
don't starts turning around like that
dog food stir oh I wish I went man I was
jealous you know what I'm very surprised
that you have not done it jfl yeah the
only I know though I believe you should
go to it's such a plan here's the thing
be they've invited me the past three
years yeah two years ago I just
cancelled cuz I had something come up
yeah this year I'm like mmm
not only do offense well just go up
there on my own yeah but then Justin
call me tell me how much fun you guys
aren't having I'm like why missed out
and it was sad I missed that everybody's
there from Kevin Hart to the old Zoo
everybody's neo everybody all my guys
were there and then you go to the
parties he know you're the part so
everybody's there and we're all hanging
out laughing yeah I shoulda went you
know and I love Montreal and the old
city of Montreal the French that means
now here's a whole I have you been there
in the winter I'm not no I'm not I flew
there into training camp with GSP in the
winter it's the cold let me tell you it
is the coldest yeah polar bears
hold us know it polar bears like I'm out
too cold dude I lost that place in the
winter man by the way you had a train
there to [ __ ] that place in the way on
GSP schedule it was a nightmare for you
boy so so GSP schedule was what was he
kind of like a Floyd man with a guy uh
train in the morning early morning early
might be one thing super early
why so middle would be
like hot yoga then after that be
training that be like gymnastics and be
dinner it was amazing blue I was young
he set the blueprint for what you know
cuz so I went on the ultimate right to
the Ultimate Fighter lost to ruin else
in the finals
three weeks later like a we got fight
free teach a school in your hometown so
when I found that out then I went from
there cuz John chamber goes my strength
conditioning coach in the house for all
the team Rashad because Rashad's coach
as well and GSB my Road coach was your
my road coach was your correct your own
coach so I went from that camp I went to
Montreal to spend with GSP in John
Schamberg Wow
that a great time mat for us now was
ferocity I didn't get a chance to meet
him but oh you was loved I heard they
told me that you got along so well you
guys should have your own podcast yeah
called fighter in the coach yeah I heard
that you're the father he's the coach hi
everyone you know why because he's so
well-read yeah he's a smart guy
I'd love John chamber a amazing person
for us and you I can't believe you guys
haven't met I know
cat kills me you guys start a podcast
Paul yeah boring his [ __ ] and called
fighter in the Caltrain look at GSP
spotty there he's always dimed up that's
stupid
you met my boys man yeah and you're
welcome by the way wow you're welcome
take it easy cuz he attacked me cuz hey
man I gets old guy here says he knows
you
what if I trained him I went why pick
please no no and then he saw everybody
selling picture booties and he sent me a
picture your wrinkly face what yeah take
it easy no he goes Kim Chi beer no wait
charge him the cheese's
see if you can see it charging the
premium yeah
but take it easy he's not he's not he's
not in bad shape there oh dude he would
do all the workouts with us and it was
miserable his workouts which the toughs
were and this is including college
football the toughest workouts I've ever
had god that's a nightmare well look at
he trance look at who's who he treated
get so nervous walking into his tray and
it was it he might get a new one but
upstairs small room now it's a huge ok
new place a huge place it's it's an it's
one of the best gyms I've ever seen it's
right your way is Rory McDonald's main
guy you know Jim Piersall the guy's
crazy ice doctor isn't he
the best shout to John Chambers yep yep
now I might move there yeah you should
sick shame although in the winter note
No Mas No Mas no mas nowhere no nope I
love it so much that I was I swear to
God the last time I was there I was like
why wouldn't I buy a place here you can
pick up a place for not that expensive
and then they go the world is the winner
yeah yeah and they all laughed at me and
here's the thing be yeah I wish I had so
much Jon's workouts what I text you man
i text you my weight I weighed in yeah
now you want me to tell the story sure
text me well hold on let me let me let
me tell what happened though let me so
my girls stepdad was looking thick and
not in a good way
and he was chasing my son around the
room he got out of breath
no I what you need get in shape and I
said how much you weigh he goes what do
you think I go right to 50 do two six
deals no way he's a top 40 Highway
Patrol he's not that big he's not that
he's six foot but he has a gun he
probably to 40 to 50 and he goes no way
ma'am this on it mmm
there's no way Papa were to scale okay
pop were to scale now now he got on no
hold on okay
your boys on the road I'm a Road Dogg
I'm on the road morning your Road Dogg
no name so you know that's what my on
the road more than you're on the road
that name you're on the road all the
time all the time yeah but I'm young you
guys I should be what road dogs do
that's right I'm trying to get as good
you guys that's right a road out that
yeah now I come into a town where you
got to eat but this is we that's what
I'm doing
spending money rolling out the red
carpet Oh hell's roll out the red carpet
aced their whiskey they want you to
taste their restaurant they wouldn't
then why that's the best do you want if
people want you yeah I don't be rude
come come to my thing I don't be rude
you're not a child the food
I still work out I ride my Pelt on every
goddamn day but if they the piece of
peach cobbler
you're gonna try it if I'm in Portland
and voodoo doughnuts sends me 12 what do
you do what are you gonna do Brian
well you got to eat some of them if I'm
in Nashville's and Hattie B's goes you
got try the best natural hot chicken
sandwich in the world
you tried hot chick and said better to
be polite and fat than skinny and rude
that's what I said don't come
you saying better to be polite fat than
skinny and rude but here's the pride
here's the problem okay I'm on the road
a lot yeah
and I said to myself you gotta think
Brennan but then I asked my sure out
thick that's like yeah I always feel
thick but you know I told my own aunt
you ask my girl how no shoes I think
it's skinny I really go ask you how I
look you look fine actually going that's
my brother you guys look fine to me but
you feel something's off so I step on it
take it easy get up on my scale is an
emotional time from take it easy breathe
up on the scale breathe that's okay
that's it if you have to bite your thumb
by your thumb the other week no reason
to squint the other week you went how
much you weigh bro NYU looking thick not
a bad way looking at thick I uh I'm
probably 50 wit no Papa it's a bubble
you ain't 250 anyway you probably do 70
and it was insulting it was in the salt
things in salt it was like you sent me a
low-carb are you gotta having some food
I know man you go you go no I'm not no
never that time never been that big I've
never been that big and you you got dead
serious and you said I never not beggin
you said it three times what did I text
you this weekend up let's step on that
scale
Brendan topped out at 273 is T top that
is 273 we got Eddie Bravo Joe Rogan and
myself got attacks
I'm 273 pounds and I'm sad I said I'm
thing about slitting my wrists yeah I'm
super sad cat don't tell anyone I'm
insecure I'm glad you're talking about
Tom right cuz I know it's gonna put me
it's gonna put baby in the corner how
much does that wrap baby's gonna lose
weight cat did you think I was 273 no
because I imagine chin said like his
biggest he was 285 and I saw the video
of his like high school talent show and
you look nothing close to that so I mean
is a different kind of big yeah really
weird like you're you're um I think your
bone structure is so make a swordfish
cuz I'll meet a guy whose inner self the
sort is you're so dense yeah you're
dense
you're welcome swordfish you're 90%
Samoan - so the Samoans have very strong
dense bodies I'm thick like a swordfish
did your but you are you are like so a
lot of guys am 240 but they look they
have a different frame and you're like
you don't look it you look you're I
think it's cuz you're 64 and you're
so super wide I don't know thick yeah
but there's been some markers I don't
want to tell anyone about so I'm on the
road I'm on the road a lot and I'm on a
plane okay and the first thing I do when
I get on the plane is I unbuckle my keys
because it feels better in my head I
went dammit my jeans again tighter yeah
it's these [ __ ] jeans yeah it's not
lard-ass there you want buckling fatter
okay okay okay take it easy now can I
ask you a question where do you put the
weight on most in your tummy but tell me
damn it you've always been a little
secure about your tummy even when you
were fighting you and I go to my tummy
my dick ah I don't know about that part
dear man describe my fat or fat or dick
like dicks kiddin put on weight as well
my favorite is this my favorite is you
ever of date girls were like and and
it's true because I get to Maya because
my button my boobs I hate it I don't I
don't go ahead people ask our inst yeah
so here's the thing Papa's losing weight
first long as I've known you you've been
on a diet I wasn't I wasn't either
another hold on hold on I wasn't on a
diet
you were not up to 73 bread I was on the
road diet so was this road food you were
just on the road eating my girls
pregnant you know so it's like there's
just food I'm eating I'm on the road
like Drake says you know if we if we
celebrated every time something to
celebrate what are we doing I was
celebrating on the road I mean whatever
sold out the show we'd celebrate with
dessert you just got you got a stop for
the first time so I thought what I don't
want is my my second child comes and in
November I can't be in the pictures with
my tits out no can't be all fat because
my kids only got a picture Mike
what fat dad was the baddest dad's a fat
ass yeah because dad looks like cop
rough stranger things yeah so we can't
have that hoppers got a little he's he's
thick
I'm hopper Brian a little bit yeah not
anymore and athletic hopper whatever
doesn't matter at this point no one's
playing sports anymore that's mom hopper
your ha so I've been I can't emphasize
enough
react Aikido really since Thursday night
gene vegetables - you getting some fiber
in your body not real ly means some
veggies I don't do that out the high
carb ones no no let's go ahead and have
a supplement for that though I'm talking
strict keto for four days now really
well see where I'm at end of August okay
how all my pop is out there long going
on some fiber - I want you on sir we
have some fiber okay
just some greens and some a lot a lot of
spinach spinach ton of spinach spinach
otherwise they'll give me your breakfast
this morning at 4:00 fried eggs I'm
three pieces of bacon okay just just
just watch you're just shut the whole
ass I've got okay just shut the [ __ ] out
what do you have just shut up here
because I'm super ornery dude no bro it
makes me clean easy and healthy skinny
and rude right now I want you put in fat
but you know you're getting skinny in
truth
I'm just saying mad at you guys what
about a second one in here what a sin do
people send your pies that they toiled
over like not anymore bro you're gonna
be skinny and rude yep but you always
have a tendency to be fat and polite I'm
just saying I don't like that no one
said you're all bristly like that let me
shut up everyone you look good well my
body's changing a little [ __ ] you man
this ain't about you okay but I don't
get exactly the same I'm getting though
you're skinny bro well you got me my
hopper body you toasted you posted about
about dad bods being sexy to women yeah
how'd you read that what there's a study
okay
all right - take it easy man yeah I
don't like it out of support in here
giving you support I said Kido children
like this you're gonna do Kido look I'm
giving you support you just seem
aggressive right now
yeah man cuz I'm mad no one said you
getting fat okay
and I don't like that I have to step on
the scale in front of my [ __ ] in-laws
they went Wow yeah I'm 73 when it's at
273 everybody went whoa is that
Christopher Pratt who is that guy yeah
that's Chris Pratt don't call
Christopher
alright he's a studdy that's so impose
did yeah well he's a big boy if you're
Chris Pratt I guess they don't really
care well not anymore now he's shred her
son your son is Fred City yeah yeah he
looks he looks red City
pop was getting in shape man
right dude okay man I don't like it easy
way what kind of I'm saying nothing dude
you're you know I don't like either
all right thanks my brother's no except
no one in here you guys see me all the
time
especially you cat no is a female
no one said [ __ ] you wear any clothes
all jerseys all the goddamned you wear a
baggy clothes sure sign again fat you're
in Jersey okay you're wearing Hawaiian
shirt there you are
I mean know that I need bro okay that's
me oh come here you where I look like
hopper no look listen he's a big kid now
let me ask y'all some batkid all right
he's got big arms now let me ask you
something
well you wear a lot of you wear a lot of
layers so I don't know
no I don't about t-shirts that's the
other thing my style is gonna change up
as well well I don't like wearing
t-shirts all the time okay I like
fashion maybe wear button-ups from now.i
dude nobody's telling ya you forced me
man to get fat what a seizure
I didn't I'm sick of this what's the
goal what do you want to get down to cuz
you when you when you did cyborg when
you did jujitsu you were to 38 to 28 I
think that's a lie price is where he got
away of the the weight was so sweet 225
and I found out that they were gonna
weigh him in they were only more to me
so I was 228 okay that's not a lies to
try I was like bring him up then he was
very thin he was super thin let's me
running away running away they didn't
engage but I thought I did I was
gardening that's beyond it was great
there it was like [ __ ] off he said
you're not taking my leg I got a fight
not happening nice submitted Matt
Mitrione right after that show up show
the other picture I'm in this guy like
that outfit you were wearing yeah bro I
was also highest-paid on the card not a
big deal yep
look at that I look thin I am there see
the thing here I baked through 28 damn
so back to my thing a good look
shout-out to metamoris yeah that's me
yep number one right gap in the world
some done anyways all the time about
high speed um oh yeah
and then somebody Matt Mitrione in the
first round after oh I'm sorry
Cave where were we I'm not in that life
anymore don't bring it out of me Brian
hey dude I'm just like you dude I'm just
looking no I feel like look at me
shutting down his guard anyway you
didn't engage in nine types anyways
we're not all Navi anymore
what we're talking about here I am shut
him down again what word can you get rid
of that chance all right but I like I
like the thin why'd you bring up
pictures I like I like the [ __ ] bring up
picture me shut him down no here's the
thing Brian what am I gonna get - what
would you like me to get - well - 35
okay that's that's who 30 that's not
gonna happen
sorry I'm sorry look at you there look
at the cutie they're lucky mm-hmm it's a
big strong kid they're the headphones
were sold they sponsor who say in Vault
Tim Tebow and me okay dude you're you're
kind of making me angry because you're
cocky and also you're bristly so I don't
like this Kido situation for you make
some grouchy no I'm not grabbing and bad
noise Sam I think I can get down to 230
I just I don't mind you being - sorry I
don't want to do the thousand dollar bet
listen me 235 look first of all you're a
lot you mean a second of all here not
know will bring a scale in here due to
40 because to 30 35 you weren't for you
to $35,000 but I need a date September
yeah right number
now it's September one Tambor's that's
how you can do it in a month that's
gonna be a march over then end of
Halloween give me enough septum
give me a key October first if you want
over first thousand dollars Chows know
that you're I do feel weaker a little
bit nope
okay I'm [ __ ] strong a twosome Oh Dee
hey dudes - are you lifting a lot of
weights no not really I do dead left
twice a week and you how heavy did you
go with the deads what how did you go
with the deads are you lifting heavy you
always looked heavy don't you do 10 reps
of 400
10 sets 10 reps of 400 3 sets
ok ok fine
you know what man here's the other thing
I feel like you're going in here lied to
me I don't wait isn't it I feel like
everyone in here lied to me we did lie
to you know who else lied with me who
and it rhymes with Bo
oh damn it what who who's it Riley it's
a device I used to lose weight runs with
Bella ton oh the peloton was lying to
you what's that thing you have in your
wrist is that a bracelet it's called
whoop talk to me about it tracks all my
stuff like what do you mean your stuff
my heart rate how many calories I burn
how much sleep I got it's gonna be very
important during this bet I need one of
those because I'm older I'll get you one
it's called whoop feel like peloton
fighting my entire life what's
difference between that in a Fitbit
because I have a Fitbit this is more
calculated more precise so I'm peloton
my fat ass you guys see my Instagram
story I'm on there every morning man
yeah this is a thousand calories burn
yeah not a thousand burn what do you
mean so I would burn a thousand go I can
have this and I was overeating so I was
it losing weight so you're like you're
always on a diet yeah because I was
calculating my numbers were off bro not
anymore thanks to whoop whoop there it
is
whoop there it is huh so these so what
did you burn you started with a thousand
what what did what did the whoop say you
burned some days 400 some days oh it's
very oft well enough but that thing's
very on very odd because it's the most
precise yeah Falls your sleep tracks
your recovery everything damn muqaam
promo code fighter get $30 off we just
do it it was organic but yeah that's
their ad all right I'm so disappointed
myself I got kids I got one coming no
don't fat let's do 70 dude you wouldn't
ever feel shy take their shirt off right
now never not Oh Oh ink magazine who did
a whole cover with post Malone did all
these big stars have to do a feature on
my tattoos yeah they go shirtless so it
nah I'm sorry that's not happening how
about your sleeveless yeah think we're
gonna do man
it's tank top tank not going tank no
just sleeveless we'll see man your
specific what about your back - anything
on your back camera mer just muscle are
you if you do that now more more more
self-conscious of a front shot or a back
shot out front back up yeah I don't
think you have you don't have love
handles though I don't think I'm a I
don't have obliques like [ __ ] yeah
Vin Diesel it's your little tum tum that
you have a problem in the lower tum tum
dude keep it up man I'm just you saying
that's what I'm doing okay--man that's
way to get my grave nope
no am I gonna kill you I'm putting coal
into my [ __ ] fire okay okay keep
doing it dude you lose that money
alright you lose that money you know I'm
gonna do with that money what buy shoes
ah man too sick addressing like copper
I'm sick of being overweight do you want
to be to throw longer I'm a dress how I
want yeah I'm self-conscious yeah I feel
like sometimes especially on stage I'm
gonna over dress people like oh he's so
dressed up
that's me dude yeah and I want to be
skinny so maybe you'll do that and I'm
gonna Forge coats okay yeah
so Brian want test and anavar and start
lifting seriously you are maybe I'll
start doing some real I'll get I'll get
serious about my strength conditioning
and then I'll just be 10 pounds heavier
but that's a good temp asset all right
ten pound all right to my ass like
special on yeah you look Jack I look
pounds yeah I'll go right to my whole my
shoulders everything now listen there's
dr. John Chambers you put on what muscle
easily if you did it right yes do it but
I need him and you couldn't do without
steroids
you ain't putting temp in the I'm not a
regionally not what rather just being
real with you no I believe yeah same way
I'm never gonna be skinny so I need I
need you gotta go on anavar line you
need steroids I do if you're gonna put
on 10 pounds ma I need your aid I need
tests any steroids okay let's go down to
the [ __ ] Venice Beach now I got some
people I can I can get I'll go to a
doctor and cap what do you think this
pet what do you think of my wait what
what do you mean just in general just in
general did you think I was 273 no
absolute
not I know in this surprise I don't
think women notice at all and I think
they probably don't give a [ __ ] if
you're 235 to see I posted they don't
care
hastily Nick Jonas was fat shamed
because he has a dad bod now - no Nick
Jonas yeah they caught him I liked him
up young sir small small and he has a
dad but yeah when Nick when Nick last
time I saw Nick he's hot-headed warrior
and he was I mean that warrior on what's
that what's the show we did boy kingdom
flunky no sir and he looked he would
look great because he was working out I
mean playing he's playing a fighter yeah
look if you don't you know what if you
don't work out you're gonna have lit up
but no Holland you can work out but if
maybe not terrible you know what he the
fats protruding through the back there
and there's an issue there sighs there's
an issue that he just got married though
he's just living his best life here look
a lot of football players are built that
way yeah they are yeah right yeah
Becky Harry though dad Bob for iPods are
[ __ ] dude yeah 273 was super
surprising to me heavy sigh burbles I'm
playing AFL you tall blaze I weighed in
they wanted me to get to 300 that's 260
good guy 261 you get older and oh now so
take it easy oh you betcha husband for
it but I was big so it doesn't matter
for a hundred pounds yeah is that the
most you've ever benched the hot note to
be I was like three and cop like you
didn't bet on it I was like three like
93 or 391
that's a lot right 400 405 I didn't do
it that's a lot of weight
Nick Joseph died piece though yeah he
can also sing oh he's so talented and a
good actor he won that audition when he
came in Frank was like I don't want that
[ __ ] guy and then he won the audition
he's just so good you gotta pull that we
gotta put those pants up though right
here so good see my fat don't hang over
like that oh it's going on that's called
a fat gun um but he got a fat gun call
the fat gun but it would tell you some
zip on the side you know what who knows
what's happening something's going on
either way he he was so good that he
changed my Kathy give it to they were
practice they were like he's a singer
and he's no Jones probably not gonna
I'm a fan of them and he was so good
that they were like he's got he's he's
the guy the Harry Oh a fan of him good
guy
oh dude I saw Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood how was it great it was right
great
I can't wait to watch it so good yeah
yeah all these women are talking about
these family I saw a post that anyone
who post see that stuff just hasn't seen
the movie
it's like saying people were like Margot
Robbie don't have enough talking links
shut the [ __ ] up you don't know the
script you know if you you like write
movies like um steals them hurt her
narrative steals the movie I mean I'll
see Brad Pitt and did they turning it in
the critic was like a celebration yo leo
leo like before she went on but I guess
it's a celebration of white men shut up
it's a great movie he's a [ __ ] he's
quitting Tarantino you dummies she's uh
she's delicious he's painfully hot she's
delicious there's three things that will
that that hurt when some certain cars I
see a car my god look at the Sharon Tate
how beautiful she was certain girls like
a goddamn yes certain certain shoes like
oh god damn I'm see I don't have it for
cars or shoes because you know cuz of
course because they're nothing but also
women yes nothing else besides women um
when I see a dude who's built with the
way I want to be built so I get
depressed yeah yeah I'll see a guy with
like long hair just a building I'm like
hey man like that yeah but you also want
to [ __ ] him a little bit no I just want
to rub down the pirate admire it you've
seen me do that I stare at them that's
like I want to look like that how come
what's he doing with his why is he
engine
yeah Sharon Sharon table there I mean
what a great casting with Margo okay
look at how beautiful Sharon Tate dude
there's a scene in there I'm not this in
squalor but there's a scene in there
where Sharon Tate in them that the
Mardle Robbie's playing Sharon Tate goes
to a movie in uh in Brentwood a movie
theater that still there goes there to
watch her big on-screen movie she pays
like during mill a day and she's in but
on the screen they're playing the real
Sharon Tate thing and it's Margot Robbie
watching her dude it is
[ __ ] it is so good I can't wait to
see it
Margot Robbie man if aliens came you
would want her to rub be the [ __ ] who
I think he bundle or what her some price
and Tom young dum-dum
he was not relevant but um she she
spoiled movie she's like this well or
alert and that [ __ ] review I was like
you're a terrible person what a hostile
[ __ ] it doesn't become the doesn't
say spoiler alert or anything no she
just is a [ __ ] a bad person dude you
know a Caprio and uh Brad Pitt [ __ ] man
they are so you're on a cap Rhian that
is so [ __ ] guys as good as it gets
and and he's the best yeah the best yeah
I think so now Brian do I Drive to the
addresses that Charles Manson and Law
the addresses in this movie do I Drive
it after I leave the comedy store and
see you guys and drive by my fantasize
things yes I do I'm obsessed with the
1960s in Hollywood you are yeah I don't
know why I do that
no it's interesting I understand that to
get a sense of the things that went on
there yeah there was a lot of artistic
power hmm in those smoke those those
areas you know it's like Ian lustick
yeah they're artists we'll hear about so
Paris in the 20s
yeah places like that Hemingway Gertrude
Stein the greatest writers painters and
everything Italy in the Renaissance what
happens Baghdad in the 12 1212 50s what
what happens is certain certain people
come there they they become famous
they're doing amazing things and a lot
of young artists gravitate there because
they want to feed off that energy really
you got to read a moveable feast Ernest
Hemingway Nobel Prize winning sure I
mean look and he lived in Paris he talks
about his young days as an artist
writing and the people he was around oh
yeah and he would write a who's so
disciplined he'll talk about how he
changed prose the [ __ ] would
write for eight hours a day you know a
boxed tried to learn how to both fight
bulls he did everything still real war
war oh oh so he would came from a
different time he was an alcoholic so he
put a bottle of wine in front of him and
he would write for eight hours no matter
what he would write for eight hours
Jesus and then after that is allowed to
tear it up wake up start again to spin
as well
and he would end every day with
something to write about the next day he
talks about it being good and hard
discipline I think it's called a
moveable feast I love that book as a kid
I read everything he's ever written but
but [ __ ] man [ __ ] you you should get you
should go down the Hemingway rabbit hole
yes you're right I think you'd right now
mean a ton on just Hollywood in 1960s
I've liked all these I bought all these
book good man since that article in
seminary was outstanding is that a
finding about how to did the people from
different parties with Republicans
Democrats tend to assume completely
wrong things about the other side how
they're way more extreme how they're
totally different how they're rooted in
hatred versus love we are it is what
because it's that it's the narrative
online so it's the narrative it's the
opinions online 20% of accounts that
gain attention yeah and and but it's
also its with politics its with
everything yes so if Drake post some
gets a ton of hate right and people not
people I ain't Drake he sells out all
his theater of concerts is the one takes
our on our on Twitter social media of of
the 80% of tweets are made by 10% of the
people like that's not the real neared
now 10% of people on Twitter do 20% 80%
of the tweets its parados principle and
I said that to you B and I go with
whether you're getting good or bad press
no and I say you text I want to which
fighter by sent this text to this
fighter
I went whether it's good or bad it's
that's not real the narrative you're
reading right now online that's not how
people feel about you most people are
like you know it's fine yes we make
mistakes
that's not real but there there's you
meet the 10 or 5 percent that it seems
like it's painting the narrative for you
and that's not real better those polls
that they do it beware of polls you know
any time they say you know everybody in
the Middle East is an extremist it's
like no no no yes not an idiot you don't
live there go there and you'll see a
difference that's the book of click
election
well a books a moveable feast I need you
to read it listen to another tape I'm a
huge fan of audible.com because they
they when you listen to a book because
you're driving you're working out
instead of putting music and put a [ __ ]
book or a course in your in your brain I
tell you man it'll change your life
start listening to books go to audible
and let go to the teaching the great
courses and you got so many courses by
these Harvard professors but they'll
teach you love what was it just call
them a moveable feast phenomenal book
you'll love it yeah but back to the
nineteen sixties Hollywood I love the
fashion then I like the cars like the
move medical stuff that was going on
then like so much of the way we live now
and the decision see to read a raging
bulls and easy riders no but easy riders
I know move yeah you need to writers
everyone yeah so so reasonably easy
riders are is about is about like the
70s and and when when Martin Scorsese
denier all these people is ha
traditional Renaissance about Dennis
Hopper dude I don't like so much of a
badass South [ __ ] drugs got in the way a
little legends amazing this hopper in
the c-class did yeah but I've been
wearing Laurel Canyon
yeah but again to your point where
someone like the doors or whatever band
you want talked about the birds when
when they're there and they're pop and
they're getting inspiration well all
these other people want that same
inspiration so they come to Laurel
Canyon
yes and Rustic Canyon Topanga yeah so
you have all these brilliant minds and
you're surrounded by it yes that's the
that's the movement the movement that's
them and it's cool to drive through
there and then when you drive through
you got Houdini on a house that yeah
which is that it's and he was there
because he's making movies and there's
just so much history through those
salesmen that's right that's right a lot
of murders though which is also engine
well that was the first time when the
Tate's when when Charles Manson came at
it it was like wait a minute these hip
see these hippies are dangerous [ __ ]
drugs are dangerous you know and it
became a pair what's weird is Charles I
forget the [ __ ] name but before
Charles Manson there was a guy same
thing who had a cult had a bunch of
girls there and would influence you know
people in Hollywood with the girls say
man my girls do whatever you want but
you gotta put me in this like there was
someone prior to me and thought yeah he
was just [ __ ] crazy
oh yeah look at Joni Mitchell in Laurel
Canyon Joni Mitchell Giants [ __ ]
Giants in the music wow dude Laurel
Canyon gaga heavy hitters
yeah men but that hippie movement became
ever got remember even rogue and I was
moving artists here oh yeah people
didn't get start yet you know it started
it didn't start and hate everyone thinks
that I start here then they the Lorcan
hippies win Tabasco it started wow the
fast and everything when you drive down
Laurel Canyon you pass the that country
market yeah they were all there like it
started here Wow wow it's so cool man
yeah it's cool anything goes they said
it was it was post so it was pre-aids
and when all you could take everybody
had was on the pill you're on the pill
and they had and you didn't have to
worry about syphilis cuz you just got a
shot in your ass and and so it was weed
and psychedelics and [ __ ] it's sweet
psychedelic I'm obsessed with the 60s it
sounded so goddamn fire it sounded so
cool yes you played music in your [ __ ]
the fashion was cool everyone was [ __ ]
yes yes they were [ __ ] god yes so the
music Laura can you talk the heavy
hitters from the doors to the Rolling
Stones were there even the Beatles came
down there everyone the whole movement
Lorcan Sunset Strip and then these small
hands would perform on Sunset Strip and
they would live in Lorcan company
talking about the biggest bands in the
world performing Sunset Strip to be able
to play the guitar and sing to be able
to write songs ah dude play the piano
even the cars back then the [ __ ] and
fashion man yep end up big come on man
just don't say 70s bush either don't say
that out loud the bushes I didn't like a
little problem
yeah well grosses me out cat
what'd you do okay Crosby Stills look at
this John says stills Crosby or Crosby
that's Crosby Stills and Johnny Mitchell
thanks whatever the [ __ ] that look at
that oh you wanna make fun of my boots
I'll get him leave his boots bro
they were so town there's so much
talented right there there's so much
talent sitting there oh god what's his
name bill Crosby John Crosby Crosby
Stills Nash and young Neil Young that
band was so insane Oh Neil Young yes
okay oh my god Crosby yeah yeah the
birds birds wasn't Eric Clapton hey do
dream top bands out of Laurel Canyon
crosby Stills Nash there what kind of
Southern Cross welcome to the other side
huh nicely ran away
um I'm not I'm not very film literate I
mean movie I mean uh music literate okay
I don't want to be a [ __ ] rocker
let's go let's start a band bro god I
wish were younger with a fighter alright
on the kid again we suck no I suck just
don't list the top bands well you got
Tom Petty and Jakob Dylan mmm well I'm
sure if there's no like Wikipedia Laurel
Canyon they do Wikipedia's Frank Zappa
oh my god Bret Jim Morrison yeah Joni
Mitchell yes Joni Mitchell
so Frank yes the history of Frank look
at the house to see house Frank used to
live in that house to grow up see that
right house yeah that's right in that
corner
that's right in the corner yep yep
scroll down uh shut the door
David Byrne okay look at this other
famous past and current residence David
Byrne from Talking Heads Alice Cooper
David Crosby Jimi Hendrix was there a
lot of Glenn Frey you know Jimi Hendrix
Eagle Jackson Browne Jimi Hendrix how
know Isis Justin Timberlake Anthony
cancer at Hot Chili Peppers
Carole King Ray Manzarek from The Doors
Justin Timberlake Peter Bryan some of
the Mamas and Papas was the big one
there the first one at Birth yeah would
you do the Frank Zappa there his history
is crazy but he was it's a book called
1968 read that oh yeah yes that's that's
the book yeah
to bring that up bring that up that's
the book and I read that's a [ __ ] love
it you know 1968 just called 1968 mom
the road I read dude this one yeah I
like to look at I like the history but I
don't like the dark this is your belly
the year that rocked the world
1968 mark on
that amazing book just wrote it down so
you don't know him I got this new book
on Charles Manson the family that'll
cover it it kind of but it's such a yeah
I'm seeing about those murders like the
girls who did it you talking about
seventeen and like eighteen and nineteen
years old girls who did that you know
and just their [ __ ] their entire their
[ __ ] yeah hey they've met a charismatic
cult leader but here's the thing is like
the you know Charles Manson didn't do it
now he and he didn't tell those girls to
do it I'm not defending trusteth then he
told his guy texts all he said to Tatsu
is his right-hand man goes make that the
murders of the the people in that house
as brutal as possible yeah and then you
know he then texts carried out the
things the murders horrible how many
people were killed all together in that
house I think before cuz he was Sharon
Tate her ex and then another couple and
one of the other couples that's what was
the daughter of the vulture shareholders
yeah area says six including an unborn
child six yeah cuz Sharon Tate was eight
months pregnant and begged for a life
went don't kill me cuz the bait you can
kill me after but let me have the child
they do what the [ __ ] you want
horrible man horrible piece of [ __ ]
that's and I don't know spoiler alerts
but that's why you got a see once upon
time in Hollywood because if you know
the deets on this murder
you will be satisfied at the end of this
movie okay okay
cat what you do this weekend I went back
home to San Jose to celebrate my
sister's birthday held your sister she's
22 now yeah okay that's all the videos
on your i G sisters alright my thirty
years younger than me yeah only
thirty-five out weird no we had at all
they are DiCaprio was a young girl yeah
be like you would you guys do for your
favorite they did a black guy jump out
of a cake unfortunately that's what she
likes
that's not racist that's all she prefers
the black that's our preference it's
perfectly cool like Jerome jumped out of
a cake yeah he's sick hmm
luckily we didn't go to the go Roy
Garlic Festival we're gonna go on side
do a shoot now a mass shooting well you
know what that fukk yeah every single
summer for three days there's a thing
called the garlic the garlic Gilroy
Festival where everyone comes and they
eat everything made with garlic in it so
garlic ice cream where's it at dark ice
creams and Gilroy where's that I it's
about half an hour out from San Jose
it's very crowded San Jose yeah north
yeah more north and it's on the way
there it's beautiful
everything smells like garlic so it's a
little off-putting after a while by Bay
you used to it yeah you get used to it
if you're from there have you guys but
you guys go every year every year we're
in San Jose for the summer we try to go
at least one of the days and the only
day you could have gone was Sunday but I
would have missed my flight
otherwise so I was gonna rebook my
flight for later but I was like huh no
it's fine we go all the time I don't
need to go so I ended up not going my
sister ended up not going we found out a
couple hours later that there was a
shooting six-year-old gets shot yeah
what six-year-old it's your own little
boy died no three people died one of
them with that little boy oh my god it's
a [ __ ] disaster and I think it was
long a dozen people and there's two
shooters do we know why
[ __ ] morons decide to shoot up a
garlic cookout somebody said that while
the shootings were happening someone
screamed out why are you doing this and
when the shooters responded back because
I'm really angry and that's all I know
about it oh so it says it's one guy
thing no there's a guy they caught one
big the police shot in one there's
another culprit involvement I think so
let's see six garlic-y Roy fist women
referred to Mike is Right manifesto
before shooting you use the ak-47 but
legally in Nevada to kill three and
munna does Moore had a six year old
[ __ ] child like a man who killed
three people and wounded a dozen more
angry 19 year old who had recently waded
into the world of white supremacy so he
might is right of the survival 9 1890
racist manifesto he then uses slurs
against mixed-race people and me
a white Silicon Valley workers claim
about hordes and overcrowding towns
you're 19 by 19 year old my strength and
violence determine what is morally right
do not tell you what do you think about
the world sometimes man and help
suicides up and the negativity and toxic
toxic culture on social media and how
people are [ __ ] these math you know
we've had 236 mass shootings this year
already so Matt in America so I means
three or more people die for mass
shooting 236 what the [ __ ] are we gonna
do what are we gonna do it's just this
these people are upset and they have
their hate to put it man but they're
UNAM not they're losers so it's beyond
the basement the selfie kill the 30
rolls online who finally get up the
courage to do something with their [ __ ]
lives and the the thing they want to do
is hurt people
there's people pieces should kill the
six-year-old a 13 year old girl have you
seen the picture don't even look at the
pictures he's such a cute kid yeah it's
a disaster that's a [ __ ] disaster
don't ya let me look at him let me look
at him that's not the one that's why the
shooter that looks like an older
six-year-old sentía that's a high school
yearbook photo but these are guys who
were they don't work hard to get where
they're at in life and they blame
society on and they live in their mom's
basement or they're unhappy cuz they
don't drive what they want are the
things just they have all these hopes
for her life her parents had all these
aberrations for them and they're [ __ ]
losers so they get online oh my god they
get online they're trolls yeah and then
they then they blame suicide because
they're these losers ya know you piece
of [ __ ] you're a troll online you're a
loser
because of you not because you didn't
get any breaks not because no no-one
gave you a shot everyone sets the same
[ __ ] Starlin you a piece of [ __ ] well
it's it's young men who are completely
disillusioned we just need someone to
place their energy got it it drives me
nuts men there's one of the reasons that
a lot of societies had a draft when
really 14-year old from the time you
were 14 time you were 20
you were in some kind of a controlled
circumstance where your days were
accounted for by older men in organized
groups
and there was a violin there was an
outlet for violence there was training
sport and ultimately military a lot of
that if you look at most of societies
throughout history there was there was
always some kind of a draft there was
always some kind of mandatory military
and a lot of that was to keep boys off
the [ __ ] street there was this guy
who said if you imprison every 14 year
from 14 to 20 the violent crime would
literally be non-existent I mean if you
look at these statistics almost and for
whatever reason at that time in in in a
young man's life you're really prone to
not only being brainwashed into bad
stuff but expressing it in a very
violent way but it's my thing that that
this loser who shot up this garlic
festival you kill a six-year-old boy who
it says just graduated from kindergarten
it doesn't matter
he's railing against existence it
doesn't matter it did the more pain he
can cause the better because its
existence he hates that's what he's
fighting that's what he's that's what
he's screaming I just kill yourself do
ya just do us all if we manipulated kill
themselves Fantan or hurt themselves and
men tend to express it outward but I
mean if you're a guy and you get angry
in your kid right you want to take it
out on people that that you have issues
with but killing innocent people have to
be some sort of mental it look a lot of
this has to do also I'm sorry with
they've done enough studies on this a
lot of us like this Isis tough young men
it's a lot of guys are just not getting
laid a lot of times this is [ __ ] some
sexual dysfunction where they feel like
losers and societies they're not they're
not getting the hot girl they're not
getting attention on social media so
they go alright well if I become a troll
at least I can join this club because
they're not in any club they're not in
the cool kid club and they're not late
it's nice no it's not [ __ ] chicks so
they go complete opposite where they
hate the entire world they're there the
eggs they're the trolls but there's this
toxic culture where the rest these guys
who have no direction have no days feel
like you know they're not the popular
kids so they join that this loser
manifestation little kids though that's
that takes something crazy but they
don't think about it because there's
magic they were like
problems at girls if you look a lot of
problems so if you look at like a lot of
these people who do a lot of violence
it's not like women are knocking down
their door did something's going on
there they don't have intimacy in their
life they don't feel like men they don't
their lies they're not successful or any
faster even if you have any other side
the far the hard left the women that are
like see see male domination everywhere
and are trying to change the way we
speak and you know or just not just
women men in that sort of hard left
feminist movement I'm not talking about
feminism work give people an equal
opportunity I'm talking about people try
to change our language and see you see
about sexual exploitation everywhere a
lot of times they aren't the ones are
getting laid either like you can see it
man it's it's just what it is yeah this
is their ugly if the women were barking
the loudest I mean show me show me what
no but it is true were like a you look
at yeah bring all the smoke if you want
the ones that are the ones that are
there's no gender the gender madness
that are trying to cancel you out and
stuff I'm not talking about people that
are intelligent feminists I'm not
talking about that no I'm not talking
about people who are actually seeing
problems in society and coming up with
ways and learning I'm talking about the
hard left academics not tens now and
they're not getting laid and I see it
with the men same with the mass shooters
name the best-looking mass shooter they
look like [ __ ] yeah they're just gives a
thing they they're not smart I don't
that they're not smart
they don't have looks so they can't take
either those boxes because I know some
so it's not all about looks there's some
girls who cerebral II will drive you
[ __ ] I mean crazy sure there's some
do too silvery bleah they're super sexy
then I have either they don't put the
time into the reading they do know that
and they're probably emotionally
unstable but at the end of the day
they're they're sad
they've been wounded deeply and it only
got worse from there so I don't know I
think they're crazy yes I think well
they definitely are baby gun but did
they become mentally unstable because of
their severe isolation to like you know
what it means they don't have a good
group of community I went to buy a fight
dude I feel like you know this one guy
talk [ __ ] to me on the internet I found
out where he lives
I'm gonna go in there I'm a [ __ ]
stabbed now you'd have all of us would
be like no no you know you're not not a
chance
not you no no wait it that's that's
right you have friends you'll have a
community to go hey how you doing yeah
thank you do that you know I'm saying I
have a group of friends who kids be like
that's a terrible idea
yeah that's right you'd be like dude now
the rest of you were losers you like
that sounds like your great idea yeah
well we wouldn't be but we wouldn't know
each other we know each other online
yes but have an online computer yeah so
there's no there's really no so it's not
real a lot of things then if you knew
the actual person like dude you're gonna
ruin your life for you yeah but if
there's no actual physical relationship
yeah do it dude you've been talking
about it one of the biggest things I see
with young people that it doesn't matter
who they are and I did it myself
and we all it's very easy but when
you're not feeling good about your life
or you're feeling like you're left out
or you're afraid you're going to be left
or whatever it is you want to find a bad
guy you want to find a bad guy and young
men in particular will find they'll try
to find one guy one group that's that's
responsible so the Jews or these blacks
or whatever it is that's where it goes
where they just go and the left does it
with you know these all these races
white men voted Trump in that's not why
they voted Trump and there's other
reasons there are a lot of reasons that
go into this not not it's not this one
thing not this resist binary solutions
you know I mean binary good guy bad guy
stuff - like - it's not the way it is
that the other side it's usually a
confluence of events that are causing
these problems it's not the Jews it's
not it's a lot of things it's a lot of
things man so it's such a yeah but that
would you need a bad guy if you can see
bad guy then you can lash out an attack
what hardest thing about life is
sometimes there's not bad sometimes it's
you yeah why you or not do what you in
life yeah the you should point your gun
at yourself it's criticized by creating
God criticized by creating don't
criticize by shooting it's such a but if
you think about how the world is got it
a bum you out man yeah that's right it's
such a bummer but there's also a lot of
good and pushback but you're sure and
like you said in that article most
people are not [ __ ] we're on the road
all the time you see the I see real nice
to people whether they're from red
states blue states ern
Saros they can be hammered we meet drunk
people yeah I mean drunk people I meet
guys girls group of guys they're awesome
and then I talk about great not talking
about being concerned they're not hating
on people there's none of that no that's
real man and I race on the ground
they're not racist no man I've met a lot
of white guys a lot of bros a lot of
dudes in red states a lot of Republicans
or are they my own guns than that racist
they're just not I'm telling you they're
not they're not if they voted for Trump
a lot of times they did it because they
wanted a better way something wasn't
working that's all so we all we all have
to be a little bit more charitable to
the other side and understanding a bit
but I think it because we're on the
ground run with our foot on the ground
our ear to the ground and you meet
people non-stop it's like that's real
you should tweet out that article you
sent me you should treat it oh you did
good good that's important good lean
gonna read the article that [ __ ]
Brendan tweeted out tell your sister I
said what's up all right she living hmm
I didn't get her birthday cue well her
birthday is technically tomorrow
oh no she likes bigger dudes let her
know I'm 273 Oh was this guy was this
guy killed or as he caught he was killed
what they caught one killed the other
I'm pretty sure there's more than one
guy involved am I crazy
Jen I think that's just one guy shooter
is it just the one I thought there was a
did he get he got shot all the cops shot
dad yeah okay
well they're [ __ ] they don't want to
face they do they want to go out fire
after all let me just pause this real
quick look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] look at
him it's not him is it oh yeah yes that
I am yeah left out um so what else does
that show you that you know bullying
kids and make kids feel like [ __ ] that's
this is what happens man these bullies
that creates this this toxic society man
you're always gonna have [ __ ] kids it
and he legally purchased the rifle I
gotta piss man hey boss I'm talking
above us okay
listen me how often do you think about
your socks like if you like it do you
use them that much you know do you ever
think about socks is for me I got socks
I wear I got black it's our hierarchy I
got the kind of socks I can depend on
they always fit tight - here's my thing
be our no-show socks I hate when I post
bit I do picture shoes of the day every
day I go you're not wearing socks what
are you [ __ ] animals no I of course
have socks on yeah low cut here's the
problem low cut they crinkle up they
fade away Obama's the guy's new low cut
which are amazing yeah because they're
made of super soft natural cotton every
pair comes with arch support all right a
seamless toe and cushioned foot beds
that are comfortable but not too thick
as a lot of times - say it again they're
comfortable and not too thick you won't
be fixing poor some part to your life
right thick is good not in the sock ease
because it can ruin your Charlotte tummy
area not in your sock think I want to be
thick that's right other areas you do
got a color so you got all patterns they
got lengths he got Styles they look
great at the gym the office out of town
okay but here's the best part be full
and for every bombas purchase you make
bombas donates a pair to someone who
really needs that's right and people
actually if you look at disaster areas
or places they need some sense shoes and
socks for real shoes and socks so guess
what feet warm by your bombas at Baba's
calm / fighter right now you om be a
s.com / fighter yep and you get 20% off
your first purchase that's Bo MBA s.com
/ fighter for 20% off the best socks you
can get no show long average whatever
you want
bombo's dot-com / fighter you use post
mates constantly dude all the time
dude red wine at 4 p.m. maybe a little
breakfast burrito in the morning maybe a
little keto friendly meal at night
whatever I need you don't want to drive
and get there their post mates my
personal assistant whenever I need
grocery give their foods wherever
whenever within an hour
well then 24 hours
de Bie and they deliver whatever you
need pretty my 365 days a year
post mates will bring you whatever you
need no more trips to the store be lazy
get the food brought to you like your
Leonardo DiCaprio everyday for him just
ding-dong whatever he wants little
diamond aristocrats have it brought to
me bring us bring it to me download the
app and start now it's free when he
download the app browse local
restaurants businesses track your
delivery in real time for a limited time
to find the kid army you guys get $100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days hundred dollars free delivery
credit for your first seven days that's
crazy
start your free deliveries download the
app and use the code the fighter a
fighter
that's code the fighter for $100 it's
one word by the way the fighter host
mates download promo code the fighter
$1.00 dollars of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days anything host
mates app bring it to me
anything you need anytime you need it
post mates download the post mates and
save with the code the fighter to me oh
sweet quick update yes he was killed by
police and they're saying there's a
potential second stuff stick second a
suspect yeah they think there's another
one right then yeah I don't attend to
short on things but then a lot of people
when they're in a mess like that they
think there's other shooters - that's
true Wow next current event um current
events yeah here we go so this clip is
going viral it's a piece of raw chicken
that jumps off of the table
mmm people are thinking it's the kind of
rigor
rigor mortis set in the chicken probably
started to activate my first time that
can't be real
but i bullshitted let's see let's see
hold up hold up hold up right it doesn't
look real but it's everywhere are you so
pink but also so in a que there's a
heart muscle look sleazy though it's a
wing right no that looks like a frog
doesn't it it does look like a frog not
a chicken raw chicken lightly stay with
it
have you seen frog legs oh I've seen a
lot of them [ __ ] looks like a
fatherly progress recent killed what do
you see so many frogs chin hey see frogs
we go fishing and leap frog I'm just
kidding no but I watch a lot of fishing
shows and again let me see that you just
say why is it wrong there Korean
barbecue yes it looks like an Asian
restaurant worth maybe like cook it
yourself seems like there's a girl that
does a grill right there I can't be real
I don't think is real my chicken would
have been dead for so long rigor mortis
when calling home but fish do that
you've seen fish carcasses do that right
yeah that's right after when it's like
flushed out and you see like just like
never see the filet just jumping around
you've never seen that I'll show you
guys that in a bit I would believe chill
so many times a lot of fish
I don't know what's going on here I
don't know I don't know whether to
believe it or not
mmm all right after cuz I only know
rigor mortis to occur right after you
killed the animal not necessarily hours
later
this is not a good one you've seen this
stuff before there's no words jumping
out half his body just flopping her
thanks Joe alive this one oh wow that's
pretty crazy alright it's already
filleted that's pretty crazy
I stand Arabs yeah but then again you
could use string and stuff it's not a
great video I don't know that that would
that weird pink piece of chicken I don't
know I got super scared yeah I don't
know sevillio Jen's get a lot of fish
though what else we got that man so have
you guys seen this video no it's going
viral it's uh this man he is doing a box
jump and it's something that he's wanted
to do for a long time he's trying to get
healthy and his coaches actually
recorded him doing it I'm not even
trying to be funny here I thought you're
gonna say he's doing a boxing match oh
my gosh a box jump so something yeah he
doesn't know arms for people listening
oh oh well she said box I was like
nobody's gonna bollocks yeah no no no
just an inspirational video so he was
born without shoulders and arms yes
don't sweat it some would say the
toughest
oh poor bunny
I ain't scared in it a lot of people I
just call me that would be scary man wow
wow wow Dam dam dam dam that's not easy
man [ __ ] what a badass yes not easy at
all man you just born without arms
mm-hmm
I can't imagine even for the fit the
parents you know it's like you know it's
having kids like my girl did the checkup
where it's like the big one where they
check for Down syndrome make sure
everything's normal and all that stuff
and you're just holding your breath the
whole time man like your god not that
you weren't loving the same but you know
at the time not a difference so hard to
live you don't want them there somebody
has to say something else do everything
for you right there
everything wipe your ass the whole thing
Jim
I cannot imagine but look at this little
badass man yeah 20-inch box jump Wow
hey that's pretty cool that's so cool
yeah that's right so an Indianapolis
officer went to McDonald's and accused
one of their workers of taking a bite
out of his make chicken sandwich when he
went for lunch and it turned out that he
actually took a couple bites of it and
then forgot because no well he got the
sandwich got to work took a couple bites
wrapped it back up put in the
refrigerator know this and he just kind
of forgot about it until he was no
that's who's protecting Indianapolis
sometimes but
oh yeah the officer actually worked an
entire shift and grabbed his McChicken
sandwich after he was done seven hours
in and he found out that there was like
two bites missing and he came to the
conclusion that it wasn't him because he
didn't remember taking a bite out of it
at the beginning of his shift maybe
would also don't make a big deal of it
he
she went back to McDonald's the next day
told the manager the manager was
incredibly Impala Jetix oh that she
would get down to who did it they were
looking to their cameras and that she
offered him food and he said that he
didn't want the food because it didn't
mean it he just wanted to know who
didn't like cops so much at that
McDonald's location that they were
willing to take a bite out of his meal
they gonna they don't like you yeah and
then later on he realized oh I did take
a couple bites at the very beginning of
my shift and then he apologized down
there okay well he apologized it's funny
that's ancient but also said it's a
[ __ ] Mick fillet chicken there are 99
cents get another one do reckon gives a
[ __ ] correct
hilarious what else you got this is in
Poland have you guys ever want to go
bungee jumping never never me neither
one sabayon no I've never done it why
not well okay so this guy's you do it no
that's one thing I would you ever do
yeah I feel like you would I would go
skydiving before bungee jump ah [ __ ] he
survived though uh ha oh that's the
worst he survived
yeah there's video yes and so luckily
and they have that thing underneath it
that big old the net it's like a bouncy
castle thingy
hold up horrifying moment bungee jump or
plunges down after court snaps yeah yeah
with a bunch of people watching - what
they called the catcher inflatable like
the flavour bounce pass it is yeah air
cushion dude pros cons pros I get a
thrill out of jumping off a bungee cord
con it snaps I break my phone okay now
high that 307 feet there he goes and
then Oh
headfirst ah yeah he's okay he's okay
but I mean he's alive okay but he broke
his back and he had internal injuries
like his organs were here no he broke
his back you [ __ ] and ruptured every
organ he's fine
that looked awful but he didn't he's a
bit he's able to move so he didn't like
you know I hold up you know how terrible
is to break you know how hard is to
break your back on America mall rat
air-cushion they're cool oh man look
like he was falling that fast but I
guess he was oh my gosh yeah under
something fees headfirst look at that
that's where it snaps to can you imagine
what he's going through
dude how about no one knows what to do
they all up oh my god he didn't have it
dope snap just not and he'd hit the very
corner of that bag - how come no one
said anything it was either in shock
that's [ __ ] they you know you know
what this is why I don't bungee cord
jump at least he wasn't paralyzed though
yeah so I just guess fix his back not
for me and is internal organs and here's
my thing though and for what let's say
it did its that's why wet lowing lowing
it's our goodwill bro cool we gonna tell
about that yeah I don't you a [ __ ] about
your budget me neither
if anybody can bungee jump why would you
do it Oh cuz I felt like I was flat
mm-hmm
yeah well don't well that's cuz of
course not but also does it matter you
get your thrills from jumping out of a
[ __ ] cord
yikes I don't get it I do like people
that jump or hang-glider jump out
airplanes
yeah what right I'll do to thrill
alright alright you don't wanna go hang
gliding go on a roller coaster sure
don't go thank Lana yeah absolutely wind
changes and you get blown back I know
it's scary but it's ya know it's like
it's like Annie stuff I'm always so
nervous today I think he's retired than
comedy that he did does that yeah dude
my planet but I'm like please stop doing
it please style thing bass can the
planet well SEAL Team six guy I know no
no that's badass because there's a
reason things crazy defending America
yeah
squirrel jumping in that suit yeah it's
for nobody
have you seen how they do what they do
yep I've seen it for what I mean hey but
why are you doing it it's crazy it's a
visceral it's the ultimate thrill maybe
is it well some people I'm I people die
all the time in Switzerland was 14
people who died in a weekend
I don't lend it to me so I want to see I
don't think badass I think dumb it
I couldn't believe 14 people died or
something in a Navy SEAL this badass
squirrel jumping dumbass yeah well some
people just need that thrill
how about people flip motorcycles right
it's like some of the stuff is so crazy
I don't get it no I do not video and I I
don't I I cannot up other you do right
in cages different I can't control if I
make one mistake I'm not gonna dive yeah
yeah hey
don't compare fighting the heceta
squirrel jumping it's so crazy but don't
go ahead and take a look at the way they
jump off those clips it's terrible
you're flying I don't understand
motorcycles I understand the thrill yeah
get through traffic wind in your face I
think we the ultimate thrill you're
flying but but you're not though you're
not flying you're not flying like a bird
yar yar though look you're all right
watch I mean I mean you're jumping ready
oh my god oh I'm gonna throw it oh my
god well jumpin hey but hey but let's
jump let's watch watch watch I know but
jump over the edge it's a lot of waiting
now is this crazy I can't understand
this but I can understand rock climbing
yeah it's on you it's stiff for this is
also on you you got to be very very
specific oh he goes but hey but like 80
percent of them died look at this wow
that's just - oh you're too close you're
too close you're too close you're too
close that does look fun oh it's
incredible look at that look at that how
do you land you pull your chute I'll see
you still have to be high up just to
land oh yeah and then you go you when
you miscalculate you hit the rock no no
you should stir you splatter like a
[ __ ] bug on the windshield
don't hit those trees you know why if
those trees does it it does look what's
the greatest I bet it's a thrill the
greatest thing of all time
where you are with the trees look what
you're on the trees hey Brian hey here's
the thing grace of all time rather bus
bus nuts dude I know that pussy's better
but look don't you you're at least over
the water here you sure the water I had
rather bust nuts I'll do that I'll do
that I would do that over the water
maybe then bus nuts with the hottest
girls in the world
no I'll bust nuts all day I'll bust nuts
there you go you're flying they got a
jet oh my god you can fly that's so
close to the ground yeah it is nothing
off I think they're like dude I don't
want to talk about it it makes me
nervous it makes me nervous
our boy Andy's done doing it right he's
done I hope he has a family for God's
sake I know look at that this is so high
up that's so crazy so stupid I don't
understand it well no because you know
no it's not for everyone it's for the
very senior you put best moments we get
worst moments for me chin so you
normally bring up what no let's just cuz
I don't want the face to look and go
that looks amazing how they want I want
to know it's expensive and then you have
to be in Swiss Avenue and recovery does
intense nope
where's the worst see that I thought
there's nothing worst top five batches
here we go not by man people die oh but
they all die yeah it's not good it's
like robbing banks you're gonna get
caught you know look at this guy flying
flying greatest gift on earth look I'm a
bird I'm a bird I feel like a bird I
don't like it I don't want to watch this
I don't know I I need to educate can't
watch oh did he get there probably dude
oh then so that's it no oh he hit Oh
Nick then top oh he's still kind of
floating though no look he's still good
he opened up the thing oh oh he's good
sort of
that's have you seen the one where
through the whole butt hits the side
yeah let's not wash this out of respect
all right
oh no you gotta educate people the sale
[ __ ] rainbows and I don't know let's
change it let's do it let's go on to
something else let me see one more crash
one more yeah no more come on people die
this way it's not good but these guys
are alive no but it's better they're a
lot people that died that way okay let's
just move on then moving on you're a
poet
this oh so a fortnight game and he
sports game was over the weekend in New
York and then these kids want a ton of
money dude they're so young to listen to
the the kid talk and his mom goes you
know the grind for him as a grind she
goes the grind for him ten hours a day
every day Monday through them I like his
job like it's a school oh my god again I
know you can make money
it ain't livin brother listen to these
kids how could they get up bid against
that ain't livin man for tonight well if
this plays my old name used to be like
mega troll so they're super super young
are also they're 16 but they stay really
small because they don't do any physical
activity so right now I make about
$80,000 a year and from tournaments I've
made like oh yeah cool how many chicks
your [ __ ] bros zero
thirty hours a day playing [ __ ] video
game I don't think it's good for you
physically no a 16 year old won 3
million over the here's their prom be
now now parents are going well you can't
make a living keep playing those video
games I don't give a [ __ ] how can my son
get that video games get outside yeah I
don't want you even saw those I've seen
those kids they're coding the coding
camps and so dude it's not there they
don't they don't move a lot so their
bodies not all frail no your CI no but
they make three million yep I don't give
a [ __ ] about the money it ain't healthy
yeah my grits and hours a day of staring
at screens I think raising that's a
little Christmas nut that's not good
next current event well he's 16 years
old he wanted 3 mil
his name's Kyle oh if he's killed though
here's Dolph and I and he goes you know
the grind it's been a tough grind grind
it you've been in your parents basement
for 10 hours that's not a grind
correctly be actually physically doing
thicker echt I'm sure it's mentally
challenging sitting down playing video
games
yeah there's a lot of skill brainpower
and skill but that ain't a grind
another mm-hmm but he's like yeah I make
three million dollars shut your mouth
all right fair enough what else you get
this Komodo dragon they only caught it
near the end though yeah I was eating a
monkey and it just finished it in like
six bites [ __ ]
the monkey clearly has hemorrhoids look
how fast sees it what I want to know is
how did he catch the monkey
it must have died fell off a tree or
something you said it was still alive
the things I caught it the things like
the size of his body
I caught it ambush predator how can he
it's come older dragons are pretty slow
though right yeah they're slow until
they need to be fast yeah I got but I I
agree I bet this thing was already dead
people were saying it was alive that's a
lot of artfully I caught it I probably
was just sitting there what did you
swallow him by and he went I'll take you
how am I just feel lizard you just want
to feel full but he's ain't taste in it
you know he sweats know a [ __ ] thing
hole if you just have a statement you
wouldn't feel it that's what animals do
yeah you're right right you're right
you're right
fern all hey girls died he has a full
girl monkey in his belly now uh-huh yep
that was it he's all done dude he's full
for [ __ ] you that's impressive
um right you're right you're right this
is a crazy story all right so this is a
lab in Arizona that takes body parts as
donations for science so families would
donate certain body parts of you know
people that passed away
sure and then they found out so this was
in like 2014 and it just became public
knowledge they would like have stuff
inside that area where they sew it on
this huge man's torso and I put a small
woman's face or smalls with his head on
top of it and they sewed it together and
hung it on the wall there's just a bunch
of crap going on there it was a it was
like a gory bloody movie yeah and then
they were selling parts illegally body
parts leave before people that would buy
it for thousands apart my men do whoa I
don't know there's crazy people that buy
a dead body human head
ha-have [ __ ] said that a lot yeah
people buy dick if you want a dick and
put it in formaldehyde Ajara
formaldehyde and do what with it send
somebody a threat hey don't [ __ ] around
this is gonna happen to you if you got
it if you got a you mayhawk in the balls
thank you in formaldehyde don't be like
holy [ __ ]
blood arms legs found cooler fill the
male genitalia bucket of head heads arms
and legs yes it's over sister's job
though you know I'm like just to cut up
all the body parts and they're supposed
to use it for science right so they were
actually just selling those parts and
they were making jokes with the dead
bodies there's not much there's not a
real there's not a lot of penalty for
you can yeah buying a human body or miss
handling of a course but it's not a it's
not that big a deal to fine look at arms
or seven or $50 whole body's five
thousand five thousand what the [ __ ] do
you do with them though
crazy people buy them don't you want a
dead body lying around oh I know you got
a dollars gross yeah God machen open up
that I'm not going to work there that
should open the bottle of the [ __ ]
bear off dicks you just we're gonna work
but imagine the smell I'm gonna put can
I put my milk in here for my coffee I'm
gonna put my lunch in if you might just
sit around eating lunch
Wow let me get on the same shelf with
the dicks but if I could just get a
barrel full of heads behind yeah they
move their dicks over side oh yeah yeah
so these two guys they play for a team
called Arsenal yep and so they've been
best friends they're like teenagers it
looked like Turks you think here they
are so the guy they saw right there the
smaller guy
özil he was driving his Mercedes truck
and it was about to get robbed so these
two guys and mopeds pulled up with big
ol knives and they started trying to
steal the truck and big guy came out and
tried to fight him with his own hands so
I show you the first part of it here
don't say truck is the G right G Wagen
what is it B SUV though
acting SUVs and trucks are all the same
they're both turkeys probably Turks
don't [ __ ] around their toughest [ __ ]
they'll fight you
I don't like Armenians or favori Turks
tough the Turks are [ __ ] no joke dude
don't ever [ __ ] with it Turk it's cute
little time here we are please tell me
they don't die they don't die it's been
adorned what I mean when you hear the
story so that's the guy trying to fight
back well that's the big big dude yeah
he's chasing after the guy with a knife
see it and as homework kind of just took
off with the home Wade leaves them he
leaves him really quick but this is in
the beginning we first run these [ __ ]
over regrets another weird thing he also
his wife was in the car at the guy that
was driving his wife was in the car
freaking out okay so if he pulled up and
this is in the beginning and then they
jump back in the car and they took off
and then they chased him for another 15
minutes so and during that Chase that's
when you can imagine going like maybe
you know swerving into him whatever but
then they finally the the two guys are
trying to rob him so then what happened
so they chased him for like 15 minutes
and then they ended up going to a nearby
restaurant they got ahead of them got
your restaurant they ran out into the
restaurant and then they finally like
took off Billy guys and what what what
that injuries happened
nothing luckily the guy was fine and
they rolled a plug on the left looks
strange that's the guy that was kind of
running away with his wife first but he
had his wife there and the guy was
defending them on the I what a stud on
the right all right down the left yeah
it also run over him though you know
yeah
[ __ ] man that'd be scary yeah and Ives
are pretty unforgiving they tend to open
you up quick you know I'm saying hard to
defend against basically a [ __ ]
balloon dude most people are
right-handed those so they're coming at
you on your left side you use the shield
you form as a shield so don't hit main
arteries yeah
or you just bang out of it pop pop bang
pop bang that was how far they flood
Jesus for 15 minutes and these
[ __ ] chase them oh yeah the
whole time that's what I'm thinking when
they're chasing them that's a little bit
on mo pods slam on the brake roll in the
[ __ ] room but I guess you don't you
know from Serbia call us you knock a lot
now yeah
Bosnia Herzegovina Croatia Serbia I
don't know somewhere like that that's my
guess oh damn check out wifey anak do
that's his wife and that's life don't
get you saw Premier League players that
get the best of the best the best of the
best it doesn't get better their studs
nothing better know the up bake and
there in Europe and there are from that
driving Ferraris bus and nut doing
whatever they want what else and I've
had conversations with famous soccer
players it's it gets a little too much
they're like it's too much little soccer
player I don't want to say you guys are
right about that bagel boss guy how he's
trying to get 15 minutes of fame yeah
so he's training over at with Kenta and
Weidman hey Chris Wyman out to my
buddies let's not huh why are you
training why hey ladies guys wider how
you stop it so was he joking they're
hanging up the boss guy was a real thing
that happened but I mean he's everywhere
now he's on podcast he's on different
interviews and then here he's training
because he wants to do a celebrity
boxing match with member that guy
antoine dodson hide yo kids hide your
wife yeah that one that's like possible
opponent for him what is that guy doing
now I don't know same thing
I don't listen now a lot is wide what is
[ __ ] yeah they're always some
wrestling kind of Shane well he's from
Long Island
he's probably lives in the area he's in
there to [ __ ] around no that is that
that is the reason why cuz he's in that
area
alright one more this is just from
nature's metal this is a stallion trying
to mate with a big hard-on [ __ ] yeah and
then the woman the female horse doesn't
want to do it [ __ ] yeah you'll see what
happens yeah I can tell you this is the
male it happens the male horse don't
tell me I'm God look at the dick yes
Daly yeah why did the female horse want
nuts she doesn't want it
well somebody give told you yeah I'm
knock them out damn it damn the horse
got knocked the [ __ ] out he died Oh
$45,000 horse to
[Music]
why'd he die cuz I hit homie right to
the head hold those horses kick like
crazy I'd say I'm I tell you that
thing's gonna kick yeah that's what a
horse can do oh yeah that's pretty soon
he died right there they said in seconds
oh wow I didn't see that going this way
try and let me see that again please
dude he now let me see that again here's
LJ startin is raring to go that thing is
like this [ __ ] podcast arm look at
that fat dick look at him just yeah I
got kicked up so he's going I'm gonna
[ __ ] this one on the back and it's just
like I'm nuts no you're not boom you got
kicked on the side of the head yep look
like it kick right in the eyes Wow
kill them all right kick clocked at 75
miles per hour some horses
hey here's know that's why your boy
don't [ __ ] with horses either there's so
guys kick on the head walk behind him
for sure don't [ __ ] with horses there's
so many other things to do with your
life no I mean so many stories about
farmers being kicked by a horse and
never be in the same what happened he's
all slow got kicked by a horse but that
was that was you always do you read
books like you read literature is always
a and well George came in he'd been
kicked by a horse he was so he and I was
like the Mark Twain sort of series watch
mr. hands one time oh my don't [ __ ] with
horse horses are that guy died are all
muscle bro you don't know mr. hands
is that it can we in the podcast of that
chain research yeah little educate can
write on it better captain we've seen it
I don't want to see that's never seen it
you rubbed your eye on for a second year
lid was down look we popped up yeah you
look like because I want cat to learn
about the dangers of horses no it's not
you just can't be have an idea
well you don't you ain't lived here and
go yeah yeah he gets fun you really want
to watch the racing icing it's not
watching but he goes hurt and dies yeah
that's what I imagined would happen I
mean well no
done a bunch of other times yeah let's
not let's not play that because it was
disgusting
hey you're a giant [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] -
what's going on I don't know I feel like
we had a good podcast but I'm hot I'm
really notes been super dark we're gonna
have some fun with cat watching the
video that's dark Kenny's [ __ ] to
death by a horse this is pretty nobody
asked for it like he's like you don't
see him die all right
no it's over now yeah he dies cat you
can imagine he died right but it's
pretty amazing footage
he's got the video is bad though that's
what video some kind of thing slated
it's dark come on this guy's staring the
horses giant dick and I'm sorry I don't
want to see something a [ __ ] horse a
third time jerky dough [ __ ] grisly no
I'm not bristly no you want to see dark
[ __ ] dude no I told man you want to see
people dying wingsuits do you want to
see people get [ __ ] by horses you know
what no the wings I say no and I'm
keeping things positive but you're not
though your car suit ease of God thank
you they make you like that you love
dense suits not bad us listen you want
to show off stupidest people run into
building this asset the realistic listen
I want you to start eating some carbs
nope oh my god you sound a weight dude
Oh money mr. hands hilarious hey you
weren't sad when the house horse got
[ __ ] killed but I was tied that
happens tear periodically yeah that was
crazy though huh just good I've heard
Lions get dying from my getting kicked
by you know zebras and [ __ ] but that's
probably how it happens pop out they do
look like kicked them in temple you know
it's pretty square out right and faces
yeah yeah he was out he's Josh I just
thought he got knocked down like crazy
right to be able to knock a horse out
yeah you're a fellow horse's head yeah I
don't like I'm scared of horses you
should [ __ ] with them you should be and
I am too listen too many white people
are to come for with horses hey white
people leave the horses alone it's
always Robin is right oh it's my spirit
animal it's my therapy get in that's not
all with him they get him install with
him
no yeah diverse a picture when my wife
got bit by her horse on the ass yeah you
wanna hate MIT a rifle or two in a
horse's fire you
think so little too into it break into
it she smells them is there Ron
attractive animals
well he's giant aa tiny and black with a
huge [ __ ] and she she can't get enough
him and smells him she goes I have
allergies but I don't care I've been
mean ties for many years and she brushes
him for way to hey I've made those four
videos I don't like it it bothers he
bothered me how in the horse is your
wife is she's so no she's so Amanda cut
it out but but women white women love
cut it off but white people in general
it starts with young girls they they
ride horses and no not really though a
woman said this will take care of any
problems with your daughter she'll
always love her horses
oh yeah that's what the horse sector is
saying yeah yeah it's taking your money
that's not true
get a nice boyfriend that take care of
your [ __ ] problems at the Crazy Horse
yeah [ __ ] the size of a goddamn bazooka
yeah it's a bazooka dick two things
Brits white people do [ __ ] with horses
and intermittent fasting on that note
that's it that's good alright good to be
back kids uh-oh I'm in Nashville
I'm Astral's Amy's bro when this
Thursday Friday Saturday okay Jamie's
natural bring in the Sun and Derrick
Poston with me tea fat cake on four
tickets I get some dope merch that will
be with me you guys have seen it my boy
Zack posted
it's the Jack Daniels B job T's we're
having hats we got merch out their
natural zany's this thursday friday
saturday and then after I'm in Portland
Portland helium that's August 15th to
the 17th get your tickets now Portland
helium and then just just came together
brother cold country casino me and
Brendan hey where's Orville Orville
California's up north somewhere always
up north it's always have known a bring
that up - where's Oroville or are we go
already first of august yeah we'll be
there
the fried horses probably horses up
there Oroville California where is it
let's go up what do you fly anything to
find Sacramento or Joe's a north of
Sacramento there you go so you fly into
Sacramento
okay and drive about 25 hours it looks
beautiful but look how nice it looks can
be nice
some boar hunting up there definitely
won't do that at home
we're probably will probably drink wine
cheese there's no hunting so we are
there that's August 31st one show one
night only branded myself gold country
casino
Oroville California after I'm in Houston
get your tickets deepak que carajo
Brian take a little break your break
from standup besides well that's right
buddy it's gonna hurt me but I got a
juvie Norville with B Narva cool man
tik-tok down for tickets nashville see
this weekend this the finala kid were
out